bill clinton of course he was effective
very good communicator so good that if
he were sitting here right now he might
even persuade me that i was wrong
but what did he do with it what did he
accomplish he had a better understanding
of black values and culture in this
country than any president since Lyndon
Johnson what did he do with it
the problem was faced by blacks in this
country segregated schools segregated
neighborhoods unjust discrimination in
the law enforcement process whether
we're talking about profiling by police
or disparate penalties in sentencing
populating our prisons with such a large
percentage of the young black male
population in this country terrible
situation
none of it changed around eight years
Clinton had two terms and opportunity to
do so much and he do you pointed a
commission of some very distinguished to
people they delivered a report which was
Noble than its sentiments but nothing
changed nothing was done there was an
opportunity to send legislation Ted
Kennedy for example this within the last
week or so has sent to has introduced in
Congress new civil rights legislation to
undo the damage done by the United
States Supreme Court under its new
conservative rule why wasn't that done
during the Clinton administration why
didn't he go out on a limb same is true
internationally it was an era for
multilateral cooperation
there was established an International
Criminal Court Clinton decided the US
wouldn't participate there was signed in
Kyoto a protocol to take the first steps
against global warming and other climate
change crises Clinton decided not to
send it to Congress there was with
leadership from our friends in Canada
and some of the nongovernmental
organizations a new treaty to restrict
the use of landmines and I've been in
countries where I've seen the limbs that
are blown off by landmines that are
still lettering the ground Clinton
decided the United States wouldn't
participate we didn't participate in the
biodiversity treaty we didn't even
participate in the treaties against the
discrimination against women
we didn't even discriminate in the
treaty against the drafting the military
service of people to the young to be
inducted into Armed Forces we backed
away from every one of those because mr.
Clinton with all his wonderful
rhetorical gifts was not willing to go
out on the limb
of course it was related to the
hostility of Congress he didn't want to
lose a fight in Congress little
different from John F Kennedy who asked
the Congress to provide financing to
send a man to the moon can you imagine
the reaction of Congress to that I was
there that day and I can tell you they
were skeptical to put it mildly and then
he sends comprehensive civil rights
legislation to the Congress which was
controlled by a so called Dixiecrat
Republican coalition but he sent it up
anyway that's what presidents are for to
show leadership yes
President Clinton faced often after the
1954 election that was often a hostile
Congress after all he was the first
elected president in history to be
impeached by the House of
Representatives that's a tough to take
so no wonder he was sour on Congress but
leadership calls for something more
number one I want to be realistic I know
that Washington is dominated much more
today than it was in my day by very
powerful commercial interests whether
we're talking about pharmaceutical
companies or outcome these or all the
others and they have their ways mostly
through a rotten campaign finance system
of influencing members of Congress to
oppose a president who has new ideas for
improving this country that's number one
I want to be realistic about it Obama
will face that but number two it is my
hope and belief that he is the one
president who will bring in with him
because he not only leads a party
he leads a movement I think he will
bring in with him a lot of young voters
a lot of minority voters a lot of
idealists who are not going to be
satisfied with Congress as usual and
that he will have a working majority in
Congress that will support the kinds of
change he wants to make on ethics on
problems of corruption and campaign
finance on changes in foreign policy
finally on getting a universal health
insurance program and all the rest so my
hope and belief is that Obama will not
only embody change but rather